Now we turn to the question of halting.
As we have seen, not being able to
tell whether a program will halt or
not plays a central role in
the diagonalization paradox.
And it's at least partly intuitive
that we can't tell whether
a program is just taking a long time or
if it will run forever.
It shouldn't be surprising then that
given an arbitrary program input pair,
we can't decide whether the program
will halt on that input but
actually the situation
is much more extreme.
We can't even decide if a program will
halt when it is given no input at all
just the empty string.
Let's go ahead and prove this.
The language of descriptions of Turing
machines that halt on the empty string
is undecidable.
We'll do this by reducing
from the diagonal language.
That is,
we'll show that the halting problem
is at least as hard as
the diagonal problem.
Here's one of many possible reductions.
The reduction creates a machine,
N That simply ignores the input and
then runs the machine M on itself.
If M rejects, then N is going to loop.
Otherwise, N accepts.
Note that because we're switching
from a language about accepting
to a language about halting,
We have to return a rejecting
non-acceptance into a looping one.
The end result here is that if
M accepts its own description,
then N accepts every string,
the empty one in particular.
On the other hand, if M either rejects
or loops on itself, then N will loop.
A decider for the halting problem,
could tell the difference
between accepting everything and
looping on everything.
So the reduction is complete.
>> At this point,
it might seem that we've just done
a bit of symbol manipulation.
But let's step back and
realize what we've just seen.
We showed that no Turing
machine can tell whether or
not a computer program will halt or
remain in a loop forever.
This is a problem that we care about and
we can't solve it on a Turing machine,
or any other kind of computer.
You can't solve the halting
problem on your iPhone.
problem in your desktop,
no matter how many cords you have.
You can't solve the halting
problem in the cloud.
Even if someone invents
a quantum computer,
it still won't be able to
solve the halting problem.
To misquote Nick Selby If you want
to solve the halting problem,
you're at Georgia Tech, but
you still can't do that.
It's not just the halting
problem we can't solve, but
we can't determine pretty much
anything about what a computer does.
Let's keep going.